[Music]
you
monster headaches suit a rationality
what [ __ ] body stop torturing me
there's a psychological component I
might die doing this
I literally might die doing this
[Music]
Coffee is life life is coffee like on a
normal day I'm dehydrated I'm probably
behind right now I don't know how to
watch Netflix without wine I'm addicted
to coffee
I love soda on the weekend I really hope
to not be to hydrate it all the time I'd
like to know what it feels like to feel
healthy I want to be not addicted to
caffeine
I feel really sluggish in the afternoons
around 2:00 or 3:00 and I'm hoping that
maybe if I just go all water I'll have
some more energy I can do this 100% good
morning everybody
so I got my water I'm ready to do this
I'm feeling pretty good
I'm pretty excited let's do this healthy
living day 1 day 3 I think I'm dying
right now
nice shoes like coffee beans or caffeine
I went into this really confident but it
was actually like one of the hardest
things I've ever done so tired and all I
want to do is just drink coffee I have
had a ton of withdrawal I just feel a
terrible monster headaches lashing out
at other people for no reason
to me I feel like this is probably the
toughest week cuz it was the change I
feel like now like I'm getting sort of
used to not having tea but the biggest
bummer I think was socialising David
how's that water thing coming buddy just
great I was just getting some water
right now which what were you going to
get in there and don't you guys have
jobs or something don't you have jobs
it's your job eating and drinking are so
tied to my social life it's difficult to
be at breakfast and just drinking water
and everyone else's drinking like a
coffee or some orange juice this
challenge is like the worst possible
thing I've gained weight the fact that
I'm drinking so much water makes me feel
entitled to make choices like nachos I
guess when I came into this I was kind
of hoping that I would notice more
energy or notice something significant
about the way I feel change and that
hasn't happened I also haven't been
super good about not drinking alcohol
like I just want to have fun on a Friday
after the difficult weeks I've like had
a few drinks and then I
to karaoke and drink a lot so we're
gonna play some kind of weird mashup of
capture the flag and tag I feel okay I
feel pretty fine I'm not too tired so
maybe I have been a lot more hydrated
this these past three weeks since I've
started the only water thing I have
noticed the walleye hit at 3 or 4 p.m.
has kind of gone away I've been managing
my sleep better so I forced myself to go
to bed at a certain time if I know that
the next day I have to get up early cuz
usually I'll just like use coffee to
cover all that up I also didn't realize
just how often in my life
alcohol is just around and more often
than not free in this past week I was at
3 different parties where people were
offering me lots of free alcohol stop
torturing me this is way harder than I
thought it was going to be this is just
this has been the way what to explode
with happiness oh my gosh
it's been a long time this is great it
is before 11:30 and in the morning it's
one week out and I feel tired still all
the times I feel like coffee should
really affect me no but I feel like now
I'm just desensitized to it doing this
life change was really good because now
any future life changes I want to make
I'm a little more prepared for my bass
lesson is that water should be what you
drink as a baseline I can't tolerate
coffee anymore which is so sad and so
difficult you're forcing me to be
hydrated and not having an excessive
amount of caffeine you you messed with
my life you changed my life
you
[Music]